so this is definitely Marvel superhero
trailer we've already had Captain
America the Winter Soldier now we have
x-men Days of Future past to talk about
this is Bryan Singer's much-lauded
return to the x-men franchise to me
that's a very welcome return because I
loved x-men 1 and 2 or thought they were
very good he really captured the feel of
the x-men comics which was at its heart
the mutant in the human struggle the
politics of that and the emotions of
that but he also was able to create some
really fun summer blockbusters and I'm
hoping he does the same thing with x-men
Days of Future past which combines the
two best x-men elements we've had so far
that of first class in the original
films those two combinations in Days of
Future past are looking pretty fricking
epic now we get a trailer song that
we've seen in a lot of trailers before
and I was like oh really they're gonna
use that one again but it really
actually did work for this trailer in
fact I got goosebumps at a few different
occasions now basically the plot of this
movie is that Wolverine is sent back in
time from present-day
Xavier and Magneto to interact with past
day Xavier and Magneto to try to get
them to do the right thing
move that time-travel movies can get a
little crazy and sometimes you think too
hard about it and you're like you pick
apart every little problem with it it's
x-men its x-men now based off this
trailer I am very excited for this movie
I love x-men when they get it right I
really enjoyed x-men 1 and 2 The
Wolverine I thought was really good
x-men first class I thought was very
good as well and when they get it right
I am a big x-men fan honestly since
x-men 2 Bryan Singer hasn't really made
a film that impressed me that much I
enjoyed Valkyrie I thought it was a good
film but it could have been better but
Jack the giant slayer was very black to
me as well as Superman Returns and so
I'm really hoping with this movie he can
find a way to reinvigorate the x-men
franchise the way that it was before
because I don't really view the
Wolverine as necessarily part of it even
though it kind of is with the
post-credits scene The Wolverine feels
standalone to me this feels like the
real x-men 3 kind of didn't get too much
of Michael Fassbender in this trailer
didn't hear me say too many lines so I'm
curious how much of him will actually be
in the movie because this is a humongous
cast I mean this cast is just big a
really big one but now that I've seen
the trailer it does kind of feel like
this geek fest of Awesomeness when you
have the two best films in a series
combined
I didn't really think about it until I
saw the trailer and then I was just sort
of like wow that's uh if that's good
that's gonna be really good and it looks
really good also I really hope you guys
got a chance to check out my scary movie
special that I did with my fiance Sam
this weekend we put a lot of effort into
that there's many many skits part 1 and
part 2 are currently up right now I
really hope you guys check that out as
you can see the background is still
scary movie if I'd but I'll leave it up
for a while just for a few more days
guys if you saw the x-men Days of Future
Passed trailer let me know what you
thought of it below I'm interested in
hearing your thoughts as always guys
thanks very much for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuffed min eyes